hey what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd
and um
big day big day for mkbhd today is the
day that i apply for a youtube
partnership
and in case you didn't know the youtube
partner program is a program basically
which allows you to number one uh enable
revenue sharing on your videos so google
will put ads on your videos and you get
part of the revenue for the ads
generated and the second part is you can
can put some pretty awesome banners on
your page uh and above your videos and
the third thing is that you get some uh
some restrictions opened up you can
upload larger video files uh you can
upload a higher quality background
higher than 256k
and uh
longer than 11 minute videos etc so you
have to apply to get into this elite
program where youtube and google go come
together and look at your channel and
decide whether or not they want to allow
you to be a part of this program
so if you think your channel uh
qualifies i'm just gonna show you my
channel real quick uh let you know
uh right now i'm running the beta layout
and i have i'm gonna go to hit the
account button so you guys can see what
my account looks like i have 200 uh 230
videos right now two hundred two
thousand video views forty thousand
channel views and one thousand five
hundred seventy subscribers uh so to go
ahead and apply just go to youtube dot
com slash partner or partners either way
we'll link you off to the same site and
it'll take you to this site right here
and you'll see it'll basically tell you
the gist of the program you've got
you've got great videos and a growing
audience so let youtube take your videos
or take you to the next level through
the partner program just hit that big
orange apply now button it's been golden
like that for about a week
so here you go you're just going to go
ahead and input the information um
necessary first of all you're going to
have to put in personal information
first name last name date of birth and
uh you go ahead and put in any other
information here then i'm just going to
scroll down real quick and you have to
put in
tell us why you want to join the youtube
partner program i guess this is what i
had last time
and i'm going to delete that and rewrite
it but basically you can go ahead and
put in why you want to join the partner
program uh you know how many videos do
you have i have more than 100 videos the
average length of your videos 5 to 10
minutes for me
how often do you create upload new
content more than once a week
and if they're not on youtube where is
the rest of your content which is why
you see a lot of partners with one or
two subscribers it's because most of
their content is on their own website so
uh once i'm done filling this out i'll
come back to you guys and i'll get to
you with the final application
all right guys here's what it looks like
when you're done with your application
everything is filled out and you go
ahead and check whatever boxes apply to
you and then go hit go ahead and hit
that review application button where
you'll be able to read over everything
that you've put into all the forms uh
the linked accounts which will be your
parents if you're under 18 like uh
tyler's computer show the tolby tech
tech man fred
just to name a few also go ahead and
scroll down and hit the submit
application button right there
and
waiting for that moment where i've
officially submitted my partnership
application
put it down submitting submitting and
it'll probably take a good second or two
to process but uh basically you'll find
out whether or not you've been accepted
uh in
a matter of days or a matter of weeks
actually i applied with one of my other
accounts which is completely blank and
within 24 hours there is a response
saying not enough viewership so within
hours i i applied with this particular
account uh and there we go partner uh
application has been submitted uh but i
i applied with one of my other one of
this this account and got denied for not
enough original content the first time
with about 90 videos um then applied
again with about
150ish videos and got denied for not
enough original content now i'm applying
again with 230 videos
and hopefully i have enough original
content this time and uh that is
basically it so uh wish me luck i hope i
get in obviously because i really want a
sweet banner on my uh my new page
but anyway that is basically it guys
thanks for watching this application
process hope that helped any of you who
were confused and i'll let you guys know
about the youtube partner program so
thanks for watching wish me luck and
peace